Yeah, thank you for
>> any other questions.
>> Uh I mean I have multiple but uh if you
put me on the spot it comes a little bit
difficult. Can I ask you one very quick?
>> Yeah. Ask me a question. Make sure next
time your mic is better because I'm
having a hard time.
>> I got to send my phone. In Genesis 5, I
heard some people say that the genealogy
kind of has an Eden gospel.
>> Yes, it does. I have an article on it.
>> Yeah, but I heard also some scholars of
Hebrew, even Christians say it's not
true. But yeah, I don't know. Yeah. So
you you
>> buddy let me tell you about scholars.
>> Yeah.
>> Scholars are either too embarrassed or
too intellectual to admit you can find
the trinity and the coming of Christ in
the Old Testament. This is why
scholarship is from the pit of hell.
>> Are you really shocked that scholars
scholars would deny that God
deliberately inspired the Old Testament
to point to Jesus Christ?
>> You got scholars like William Lane
Craig. Okay.
>> Yeah. No. Yeah. I know it's a joke.
Yeah, I know it's a joke. I mean, I
don't want to
>> Yeah,
>> I'm going to give you the article, but
here scholars like William Lane Craig.
Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> He says you will not be able to find the
Trinity in the Old Testament. There may
be hints and illusions,
you know, illusions to it, but no. And
yet the early church fathers and writers
all use the Old Testament
>> to prove the Trinity or to prove that
Jesus is the second divine person in the
Old Testament. Right.
>> Yeah. I know. It's crazy.
>> I'm gonna trust everyone what you're
talking about. Before you leave, let me
just get it. All right. Let me see now.
Even see, I don't even know the name of
my own article. See how stupid I am?
[laughter]
>> It's full.
>> Where the heck is this? Hold on. Let me
see.
>> Can I super quickly steal?
>> Yes. You ask me another question as I
look for this article. Sorry, man. I'm a
loser.
>> YES.
>> AHA.
>> OH, NO. BROTHER, YOU ASKED ME YOUR
QUESTION. Here it is, guys. He's asking
me the names in G
the names in Genesis 5, the genealogy.
Is there a message pointing to the
gospel? YES, THERE IS. [laughter]
>> OKAY, GO AHEAD. WHAT'S YOUR QUESTION? I
want to bring it up.
>> No, I was I was trying to steal men that
argument. And basically what this
scholar was saying is that yes, it is
there if you
>> Oh, you said it's there.
>> Yeah, but it will never come to you if
you read it for the first 10,000 times.
Like you really need to read into it.
That's what he was saying. Like,
>> yeah.
>> Didn't Jesus tell us that the entire
scriptures point to him? And reader, let
me tell you what Jesus tells you to do.
Read Matthew 13:52 for me.
>> Matthew 13:52. I'm going to go into the
article, guys. I'm going to show you the
article
>> and we're going to go through it for my
balding friend.
>> Very bald.
>> Shave your head, dude. You're fighting
losing battle. Yeah. 13:52.
>> Okay. Now, read for me. Matthew 13:52.
I'm going to go full screen so people
can see it. Guys, there's the link.
Revelation of the Gospel and Adam's
genealogy. You guys have it there? Now,
read for me Matthew 13:52. And I'm going
to go through the names. Each name, if
you go back and see what it means,
you'll find it points to Christ. And I'm
going to show you. I have it here
documented. Who cares what scholars say?
Say, "Hey, scholar, I'm running out of
toilet paper. Can you give me your PhD?"
[laughter]
Okay. Read now Matthew 13:52.
>> [clears throat]
>> Then say he unto them, therefore every
scribe which is instructed unto the
kingdom of heaven is like unto a man
that is an household there which
bringeth forth out of his treasure
things new and old. Did you catch it?
Jesus saying if you are a scribe, a
teacher appointed by the spirit to
teach,
>> then your focus will be to dig into your
treasure box, the Bible. find these
treasures that are in the old and the
new.
>> Yeah.
>> You see what the Lord said?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> The Lord is telling you, the Holy Spirit
deliberately put treasures there to be
found. And those who are zealous and
seeking from their heart, God will then
reward them by finding those treasures.
>> Wow.
>> The verse. It's right there. Right. Let
me show the people the verse we just
cited. So am I going to trust Jesus my
lord who said there are hidden treasures
in the old and new testament. There are
treasures placed there deliberately by
the spirit and it will be the reward of
that sincerely
seeking scribe who from his heart cries
out to the spirit show me. His reward
will be the spirit will help him find
these treasures.
>> Yeah that's that's crazy.
>> Here let me give you the verse for
everyone else so you can see. Here it
is. And then I'm going to go through the
genealogy. It's right there guys. I may
do a session on it. Don't listen to
scholarship, man. Scholarship is gonna
make you lose your faith entirely.
>> No, I mean, yeah. I mean, if it's
Christian scholarships, I kind of try to
listen to them just to know what they're
up to. But yeah, you're right that
sometimes they're not super. And he said
to them, "Therefore, every scribe,
meaning a teacher of the the law of God,
instructed who's been taught concerning
the kingdom of heaven, the rule of our
God, is like a householder who brings
out of his treasure chest, his treasure,
things new and old." Your Bible is your
treasure chest.
Your Bible, old and new, notice things
new and old. Reference to the New
Testament, reference to the Old
Testament,
new and old. Did you catch it? Here the
Lord is alluding alluding to the fact
the Bible will be divided into old and
new testaments. Here's an illusion.
New new testament old testament. And you
need to seek the spirit from all your
heart having no doubt that he will
reward your earnest seeking for the
wisdom to know his word. So then you can
live in love and appreciation to the
Lord.
>> That they will then discover these
treasures that are there. So the Lord's
saying to you, there are hidden
treasures waiting for you to discover.
But I only allow those who seek me with
all their heart, with all their passion,
who want to really know my word. I will
reward them by finding these treasures.
Now, with that said, if you guys got it,
let me show you now the genealogy. I
give you the list, and I'll come back to
you in a minute, brother, to show you.
If you go here on my list, you're going
to see the names. I even give you the
meaning and I highlighted what the names
are. Like Adam, you can't see it. Adam,
Enoch. When we go through the list,
here's what you get, brethren. I give
you the link to the lexicans tell you
that these names mean this. All right?
Now, watch.
Watch here. We're going to go through
what it means.
And then, so you know I'm not lying, I
then give you the definition of the
names and give you links to the
lexicans. See here, the lexical data.
You see it? And I tell you what Adam
means. So after I give you the name of
Adam and what it means and Enoch and so
on, what Seth means, then we decipher
the message. Now I didn't invent this. I
had heard this from someone, but I
decided to check see I don't just want
to parrot things. So what I went what I
did was I went back and then I tried to
find whether the definitions of the
names were true. There were mistakes in
the original version. I heard they made
some mistakes. mistransations. So, glory
to God. All glory to the spirit. I
corrected those mistakes. But let's go
to the message. Are you ready? What's
the message? And then we'll open up to
your question, sir. Just, you know,
don't be upset with me. Are you okay?
Don't cry for me, Argentina.
Here's the message.
You see it? You see the message right
there? Can I read it for you guys? Can I
read the message or you guys bored? Can
I go on for another hour or you want me
to just retire because I'm too mean. I
don't see J and you fam. There's no
fruits.
Hear the message. The name Adam and
Sethanol. Here it is. Adam means man.
Here you go. Here's the article again. I
may do a session on this man. Hold on.
Here's the article again. Oops. Sorry.
>> Oh, I can't hear you. Mute yourself,
sir.
>> Sorry.
>> All right. Here you go. Here it is.
Here's the link again. And let's go
through the message. All right. Lanto,
get ready. Get ready. A man, that's what
the word Adam means. That has been
appointed. That's what the word Seth
means, appointed. Go and look at the
evidence. Don't take my word for it. a
mortal
who comes to purchase a people to be his
own possession, being the one whom God
praises and who is himself the praise
God that has descended to train up and
teach mankind the paths of salvation. He
has dedicated himself to fulfilling
God's will by luring himself in status.
He did this in order to experience a
violent death.
Being thrust through by a spear. I'm not
lying. The names have the meaning.
Spear, violent death. In order to bring
about the rest to a world that
desperately needs it. That's the
message. You may think I'm lying. That's
the message. The word Noah no means
rest.
That's the message. You want me to read
it one more time? One more time.
You want me to read it one more time,
too, brother?
>> Yes, please.
>> Okay, one more time, brethren. I know
there's 16 second delay. You got the
article, right? One more time. Yep. Hey,
you. I'm not lying. The link is there. I
give you the lexicon so they can't tell
me I'm lying.
A man, because the word Adam means man
that has been appointed. I'm gonna
emphasize the translation of the names.
Appointed. Seth means appointed. A
mortal
who comes to purchase
a people to be his own possession
being the one whom God praises mahal
right mahal
that means God praises praised God
that's what mahal means and whom who is
himself the praised god that has
descended
to train up and teach right y mankind
Enoch these are the names the path of
salvation he has dedicated
himself to fulfilling God's will by
lowering
himself in status he did this in order
to experience a violent death
means a violent death okay being
thrusted through by a spear it also has
the implication of being speared in
order to bring about the rest. N means
rest to a world that desperately needs
it.
There it is. I'm not lying. Go back and
look at the lexicans and don't let the
scholars discourage you. Who gives a
damn what they say? All right. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. No, Sam, you're reading too
much into it, Sam. That's not what it
say. Sam, I don't see Jesus anymore.
Where's Jesus?
All right. Did you get Did I help you?
>> That was awesome. Thank you very much,
Sam. It was uh mind-blowing, especially
the the part about the uh these angels
doing all these miracles and earthquakes
and all. I mean, I never thought about
it and crazy.
>> Now, you got all the verses, right?
>> Wow. Yeah. I'll go listen.
>> Come back when I have another Q&A this
week and ask more questions. So,
>> awesome. Thank you, my friend. I pray
for you and your daughters to be united
soon.
>> Thank you, brother. Lord preserve you.
>> Byebye.
>> See guys, scholars though. scholars.